The next thing I'd like you to do is add
the same caching to the permalink pages.
Specifically the same way we did on the front page,
display the age of the query that generated
that page on the page somewhere.
I'll give you a demo on how this works on my site.
If we go to one of these posts, we can see that
this was recorded 0 seconds ago.
As I reload this page,
this timer increments.
That's how it should work and if I'd already
click on a--I'd probably go to a different post
we see that this one is 0 seconds ago.
And as I reload this page,
this one increments as well.
Now, in order for us to test this, we're
probably going to submit some new posts.
I'll make sure "/newpost" still works.
And my net made it so--so you have to log in as spez to submit your posts,
so you guys would quit submitting spam to my site,
but the rest of you should make this accessible.
If we submit a new post like so,
this redirects to the permalink page
where we see we are 0 seconds old.
And when we go to the front page,
we see our post here.
If we scroll down, we can see how old
our caches, which is 55 seconds,
which is about how much time it
took me to go out and ask Shawn
to stop submitting spam to my
blog while I'm recording.
If we go back to this permalink, we
can see that it updates accordingly.
When you've got that working,
submit a URL to your blog here.